dans deux lire cet excellent l'ouvragé
en entendant et en attendant d'entendre
les annonces d'olivier véran également à
suivre à partir de 18 heures si le
figaro live on débattra aussi de jean
castex face à la crise qu vide en
recevant les maires de plusieurs grandes
villes
aujourd'hui est ce que le premier
ministre a trouvé la bonne méthode
et là aussi on attend vos peaux nues
mais d'abord donc cette question qu'on
vous pose sur twitter ce soir emmanuel
macron peut-il relever le défi du
séparatisme
on va regarder dans un instant quelle
mesure pourrait devrait en tout cas être
annoncé demain par le président de la
république dans son intervention qui
sera aux mureaux et bien sûr à suivre
sur figaro live en tout cas en tout cas
il est très attendu il y a urgence les
spécialistes le rappelle d'abord
thibault de montbrial est également
l'ancien inspecteur de l'éducation
nationale
auteur d'un auteur d'un rapport du même
nom jean pierre aubin il ya le constat
d'un pays qui se fracturent et qui se
fracturent parce que depuis trop
longtemps à tous les échelons
institutionnels l'autorité a été
abandonnée dont on se demande si nous
n'allons pas un vivre là une troisième
vague terroriste appelée allons
maintenant un terrorisme islamiste qui
se structure en france même mais vous
savez c'était inéluctable
nous avons aujourd'hui et sur notre
territoire des gens qui sont aguerris
aux combats qui ont le goût du sang dans
la bouche et qui ont la capacité de
recruter de former et de coordonner des
gens qui sont nés en france et qui ne
demande qu'une chose c'est de détruire
notre propre pays pour promouvoir la loi
divine au nom de laquelle voilà mon
combat quand on est face à un
développement dans certaines zones en
particulier la seine-saint-denis de ces
écoles hors contrat pour certaines ce
sont des écoles salafistes met donc en a
sans doute besoin de textes législatifs
pour être plus efficace par rapport à
ces écoles arts le cadre de ces écoles
sera normalement évoqué par emmanuel
macron avec notamment une plus grande
surveillance
selon les informations de nos confrères
arthur berda et christophe cornevin bien
sûr l'article dans lequel se trouvent
toutes ces informations est à retrouver
sur le site du figaro on va demander à
julie
non de le mettre dans le chatt juste à
côté de ce player autres mesures qui
devraient être annoncées vous le voyez
l'islamisme sera bien désigné comme le
principal ennemi interdiction des lieux
de prière improvisée dans les
entreprises de transport ou les
aéroports interdiction d certificat de
virginité et donc renforcer le contrôle
des écoles hors contrat et la
scolarisation à domicile 20 centres et
volé selon ces éléments est ce qu'on
peut dire que même après on répond au
défi il faut avoir le l'intégralité du
des propositions et de la vision qu'il
va développer demain dans laquelle on
sait déjà qu'il y aura un aspect
défensif avec un certain nombre de
règles et de possibilités
administratives et sécuritaires
et puis un aspect disons offensif avec
un certain nombre d'éléments plus
sociaux qui touchent plus à l'éducation
pour essayer d'éviter justement la
séparation
je pense qu'il faut d'abord revenir sur
cette notion de séparatisme islamistes
il se trouve que le figaro a publié en
2018 c'était en mars un manifeste publié
par 100 intellectuels et politiques avec
kouchner y avait de nos rails avec effet
lek
c'était des gens des gens très varié qui
qui qui alerté le président de la
république sur sur ce phénomène
le lendemain benjamin griveaux qui était
porte parole du gouvernement à l'époque
avait dit que cette pétition il ne
l'aurait pas signer parce qu'il la
considérait comme stigmatisante
donc on voit le chemin parcouru chez
emmanuel macron qui partageait je pense
à l'époque le point de vue de benjamin
griveaux et qui maintenant à l'air
d'accepter ce phénomène ensuite moi j'ai
toujours un doute il faut voir les
mesures dans toute leur précision
mais dans leur ville législatives dans
laquelle nous sommes depuis une
quinzaine d'années notamment sur les
questions de sécurité et sur ces
questions là
je me demande si l'exécutif devrait pas
d'abord exécuté
et s'il faudrait pas simplement
commencer par appliquer la loi je ne
crois pas que la loi soit appliquée je
vais prendre un seul exemple d'après
j'ai laissé la place à lucile schmid
mais il faudrait savoir pour faire un
retour sur expérience notamment la loi
sur la burqa qui a été votée en 2010 ce
qui est une voix qu'on pourrait dire
contre le séparatisme l'a mise puisque
c'est tard c'est un vêtement qui
témoigne d'une volonté de séparation
avec la la sphère publique
je ne crois pas que cette loi soit
appliquée aujourd'hui en france
véritablement et donc je trouve qui a
toujours un danger à surenchérir dans le
discours et dans la pratique législative
quand ya pas une exécution déjà des lois
existantes
j'ai fini vous allez continuer un
problème donc justement est ce que le
problème c'est pas plutôt le fait que
les lois ne soit pas exécutée ça fait
votre réponse à 20 cents et puis
peut-être une autre question
lucile celle de christophe qui nous dit
pourquoi parler de séparatisme quand en
réalité on parle de communautarisme
islamistes c'est une autre question de
nicole qui pratiquent le séparatisme à
part les islamistes donc pourquoi parler
des séparatismes aujourd'hui est
visiblement d'après en tout cas ce que
disait arthur berda christophe corne la
l'islamisme sera bien désigné comme le
principal ennemi est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça je pense
qu'effectivement les internautes ont
raison de souligner le malaise en termes
de vocabulaire de sémantique qui traduit
sans doute un malaise politique c'est à
dire que il est assez rare qu'on
on sente la dir ont sorti du derrière
quelque part sur cette histoire là c'est
à dire que on part du communautarisme et
puis il ya le discours de macron à
mulhouse en février qui se met à parler
de séparatisme avec l'idée d'avoir ont
trouvé un concept un terme qui ne
stigmatiserait sans doute moins
l'ensemble des musulmans parce que je
pense qu'il faut appeler un chat un chat
et et qui stigmatise rien on va en
famille on désignerait en revanche ceux
qui veulent se séparer de la république
et non pas l'ensemble des musulmans
donc on peut considérer que c'est une
intention louable la deuxième chose
c'est que aujourd'hui ce qu'on entend
dire c'est que ce sera pas une loi sur
le séparatisme amiénois sur les
séparatismes alors peut-être que ça sera
pas le cas peut-être que ça sera pas le
cas demain ils ont peut-être que
peut-être que demain ce sera le
séparatisme musulman qui sera désigné
marlène schiappa adil inverse
il ya quelques heures elle a dit qu on
désignerait toute forme de sectarisme et
que les questions d'égalité homme femme
sera aussi traitée dans cette loi moi je
me demande s'il n'aurait pas eu quelque
chose à faire qui aurait été davantage
d'appeler sa nouvelle loi sur la laïcité
pour être franche
et je trouve que là il y aurait quelque
chose d'un peu plus fort qui aura été
dit mais le problème dans lequel on se
trouve c'est qu'on est dans un contexte
de terrorisme qu'on est en train de
vivre l'attentât de charlie hebdo et que
personne n'a vraiment en tête je crois
le séparatisme au sens flou du terme
tout le monde a en tête le terrorisme et
la violence donc comment est-ce qu'à
partir de là le politique à la fois
traité un séparatisme culturelles qui
existent et notamment vous l'avez
rappelé sur la question de l'égalité
hommes femmes et la manière dont
certaines fans leur coeur oui c'est à
dire la guerre la question de la burqa
mais aussi on peut dire certains hommes
qui refusent de serrer la main des
femmes enfin c'est aussi un comportement
de certains hommes vincent
donc il ya en tout cas c'est le flux
audio bon il ya un séparatisme qui joue
beaucoup sur le plan culturel sur hommes
et femmes je ne crois pas que c'est la
loi qui va changer ce genre de choses et
pour répondre donc parce que je crois
que le débat doit doit s'engager
je pense que ce qui est très fort c'est
qu'une loi n'a jamais permis de lutter
contre un une transformation culturelle
quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer et donc sans doute faut-il mieux
appliquer les lois qui existent et
surtout comment fait-on pour en termes
d'application des lois pour avoir dans
les quartiers des personnes qui nous
explique ce qui s'y passe
soyons clairs des indicateurs sur la
police mais aussi des associations amies
des alliés moi je voudrais pas dire
quelque chose sur les certificat de
virginité
parce que j'entends que c'est
merveilleux qu'on va interdire les
certificat de virginité et puis
j'entends aussi des interviews de
certains médecins qui en font dans
seine-saint-denis ce tour à saint nic
évoqué ça doit exister ailleurs aussi et
qu'ils disent mais au fond si on
supprime ça il ya des jeunes filles qui
vont se retrouver
harcelée confiné dans un dans une dans
une sorte de aux mains de leurs pères de
leurs grands frères de certains hommes
violents et donc il y aura une
augmentation de violences subies par
certaines jeunes filles
le problème qu'on a c'est qu'une loi sur
le séparatisme il faut pas qu'elle soit
faite pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
la vie dans ces quartiers pour nous
satisfaire et dans un point de vue
électoral parce que moi je crois que
c'est pas un hasard si elle sort
maintenant je crois que c'est parce qu
emmanuel macron été convaincu par votre
appel je pense qu'il ya aussi une
manière d'anticiper sur les débats de la
présidentielle il a compris mais bon qui
a une nécessité électorale
ça c'est une évidence après je sais pas
si le fait qu'ils soient
l'homme le plus renseigné de france n'a
pas fait aussi qu'il a quand même évolué
parce qu'il a un certain nombre
d'informations qui lui reviennent
mais ensuite sur la le le problème que
vous posez et le problème très vieux et
très complexe de la loi et les moeurs et
je pense qu'un des problèmes dans notre
approche c'est que nous ne sommes pas
capables de défendre un art de vivre
comme s'il était défendable
j'ai eu un exemple très concret secure
cela van der leyen a voulu créer
représente la commission la président de
la commission européenne a voulu créer
un commissariat l'art de vivre européen
dans lequel il y avait égalité hommes
femmes il y avait un certain nombre d'
usage et qu'elle a tout de suite été
accusé de dérives identitaires et
qu'elle a dû reculer sur cette notion et
à partir de là je ne vois pas comment
parce qu'on va pas à simplement avec la
loi et les flics décider des choses si
on vient à l'exemple de la burqa qu'est
ce que dit la loi
la loi ne dit pas
les musulmanes radicaliser n'ont pas le
droit de porter sa élit 10 en france en
ce qu'on montre son visage que les
masques une espèce d'exception mais qui
est due à la situation mais eddy en
france on montre son envie d aller je me
souviens d'une conversation avec henri
guaino sur le voile à l'université où il
disait mais pourquoi va-t-on nous
réformer l'islam c'est pas notre boulot
en revanche on peut dire en france les
garçons n'ont pas de casquette pendant
les cours en amphi et les femmes
montrent leurs cheveux parce que c'est
comme ça que ça se passe et que c'est
comme ça que sont nos moeurs et nos
usages mais ça ça c'est pas dans la loi
c'est dans l'éducation c'est dans la
diffusion d'une forme de culture et
c'est même dans la fierté de ce que nous
sommes
or très souvent on n'ose pas le dire
alors on a un mot exceptionnelle qui est
un très beau mot mais là qui devient une
espèce de paravent absolu qu'est le mot
république et qui va jusqu'à la tenue
républicaine pour jean michel blanc
coeur parce qu'ils n'osent pas dire
tenue décente et parce que cette
évidence la de l'atelier descente il
veut pas la dire donc il me semble que
que les décisions législatives ne
permettront pas de régler ce problème
qui est un problème de rapport à nous
mêmes quand je dis nous c'est la
collecte la collectivité à notre
histoire à notre identité à notre
culture et qu'il faudrait que nous
aimions plus ce que nous sommes pour
donner envie aux autres peut-être de
vivre mais dans le sens de ce que vous
dites moi j'ai été le pardon si les
internautes ont besoin de prendre la
parole vincent mais mais mais ce qui
m'avait frappé c'est que gérald darmanin
pour défendre cette ce projet de loi à
employer un terme est incroyable c'est
la loi s'appelle quand même sur le
séparatisme ou les séparatistes menadi
seynois sur le vivre ensemble des
français parce qu'il faut que les
français vivent mieux ensemble
et là je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qui
se passe là il ya un truc de confusion
c'est à dire que dans ce cas là est ce
qu'il n'est pas possible de donner à une
loi un titre le titre d'une loi au fond
c'est comme ça qu'elles existent dans
l'espace public c'est chaque personne ne
va aller lire les articles de la loi et
ce qui est très frappant c'est que les
articles d'ailleurs sont un peu
hétérogène ya la fois quelque chose sur
le droit des associations et à quelque
chose sur les écoles confessionnelles
il ya évidemment des choses sur les
imams et ça c'est très important c'est à
dire que la question de financement des
mosquées et des
mam étrangers c'est un point essentiel
sur lequel on a beaucoup reculé depuis
20 ans mais à partir de là est-ce qu'on
pouvait pas trouver une expression qui
renvoie à l'idée du projet de société
que nous portons ensemble oui alors il
ya peut-être cette question là où le
soleil il y en a une autre qui est
soulevée par cette part cet internaute
question sensible bien sûr mais est-ce
que healy pour lutter contre le
séparatisme
il faut d'abord lutter lui estime en
tout cas où elle estime qu'il faut
lutter contre l'immigration car nous
avons atteint la saturation
parce qu'il veut dire par là certaines
formes de l'immigration d'un trop-plein
d'immigration moi ce que je pense c'est
que ça révèle effectivement le fait que
lorsqu'on parle de séparatisme
on a l'idée que ce sont les migrants les
musulmans enfin il ya une espèce
d'amalgamé qui se produit alors même que
ça a été dit par l'un de vos
intervenants
il disait ce sont des personnes nées en
france qui portent l'envi d'un
séparatisme culturel donc je crois que
le sujet c'est aussi que chaque français
chaque personne qui vit en france
d'ailleurs quelle est la nationalité au
pape puisse se sentir solidaire d'un
projet de société comportent ensemble
sur la question des migrants
je crois qu'il ya une espèce de
télescopage dans l'actualité entre le
terrorisme beaucoup d'agitation et
beaucoup de débats sur la fermeté en
matière de migration sur lequel il ya
beaucoup de communication
gouvernementale et notamment du ministre
de l'intérieur
et puis il ya cette loi est au fond ce
qui est important et j'espère que les
manuels macron le fera demain dans son
discours c'est qu'il explique bien en
quoi cette loi n'est pas seulement une
loi anti-terroriste masqué d'ailleurs
que qu'est ce qui se passe avec ça
comment ça peut servir
c'est pas seulement une loi policière
pour moi c'est pour ça que disait il
aurait fallu l'appeler nouvelle loi sur
la laïcité parce que la laïcité
moi je me rappelle d'une chose très
importante discutant lorsque j'étais au
parti socialiste avec l'un des
dignitaires du parti socialiste chargé
des questions de laïcité il parlait la
loi de 1905 je dis bon d'accord mais le
sujet de l'égalité hommes-femmes comment
est ce qu'on lit mais dans des poids sur
la laïcité il en était pas question en
et là ça devient un élément de cette loi
et personnellement je trouve ça très
important
deux ans après 1905 on n'a pas donné la
loi le droit de vote aux femmes parce
que les partisans de la loi de 1905
avait peur que justement des femmes qui
votent vote pour les peaux pour le parti
des curés
oui parce qu'il faut quand même dire il
ya des éléments lui 6 millions d'ha cité
qui nécessite des ajustements
administratif au moins pour permettre
ensuite de lutter contre cette dérive
mais ensuite il me semble que si demain
le discours d' emmanuel macron exprime
une volonté politique importante de
l'ordre d'un plan comme on dirait qu'il
ya un plan marshall ou un plan pour
répondre à la question vous posiez au
début ça voudra dire qu'il peut se
passer quelque chose parce qu'en fait il
faudrait mettre en ordre
la machine de l'état pour qu'elles
s'attaquent véritablement à ce problème
et ça n'est pas le cas c'est à dire que
pour le moment on leva qu on le cache ça
n'existe pas il ya eu cette révélation
inouïe de françois hollande dans le
livre de gérard davet et fabrice lhomme
ou françois hollande qui se faisait le
chantre d'un vivre ensemble harmonieux
leur confier ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
la partition c'est vers là qu'on voit la
partition président de la république à
l'époque qui était donc l'homme le plus
renseigné de france donc c'est une
réalité connue de ceux qui ont les
renseignements que l'on a dissimulé et
alors là est ce qu'on fait des
gesticulations ou est-ce qu'on a une
volonté politique mais ça sera très long
ça sera pas seulement législatif ya un
problème d'éducation
encore une fois il ya un problème de
définition de ce que nous sommes
ça c'est que c'est quelque chose on ne
pourra pas y échapper
parce que là si on enrobe dans les
séparatismes c'est qu'on n'ose pas dire
c'est comme vous le dites on portillon
donc si si ce que décrit dans son
discours demain emmanuel macron c est ce
qu on attend depuis deux ans une
véritable vision une véritable volonté
une véritable détermination alors
peut-être qu'en fin
on pourrait espérer quelque chose il ya
aussi une chose qui est importante c'est
que je crois qu'on peut pas parler des
musulmans à leur place aussi je peux en
train de dire que seul un musulman peut
parler des musulmans mais on ya un débat
au sein de chez les musulmans de france
certains
le président du conseil des musulmans de
france a dit que le terme par exemple
séparatiste était mieux que le terme
communautariste parce que pour lui ça
rentre ça rendait compte de comportement
qui n'étaient pas acceptables en
république mais ce n'est pas le cas de
certains enfin c'est pas le cas pour
l'ensemble des dignitaires musulmans
donc au fond or tous les cas pour aller
dans votre sens cet après midi le
recteur de la mosquée de paris le
nouveau recteur d'une mosquée de paris
lui reconnaît qu'il ya un problème de
séparatisme de facto en disant que le il
ya toute une partie de la communauté qui
ne reconnaît pas dans le public ça pose
un problème mais mais certains recteurs
le reconnaissent certains dignitaires le
reconnaissent mais c'est un débat qui va
agiter les musulmans de france
parce que évidemment leur immense
majorité et c'est s'est montrée études
d'opinion après études d'opinion sont
citoyens républicains sont français ou
résidant en france et respectent les
lois de la république
donc l'enjeu le terme de stigmatisation
en fait ils renvoient pas moi j'en ai
marre de ce terme anglais et je ne suis
pas musulmane mais mes jeux je dois dire
que l'idée que chacun assume sa
responsabilité lorsqu'il s'agit d'être
partie prenante de ce vivre ensemble est
quelque chose qui me plaît davantage
c'est à dire que je crois qu'il faut
aussi renvoyer les musulmans de france à
leurs responsabilités faut aussi
renvoyer les mères à leurs
responsabilités ce que je voulais dire
tout à l'heure des réactions
l'application de cette loi on a besoin
d'élus locaux et pas seulement d'un
débat qui soit un débat ultra symbolique
il transpire envoyer les les forces de
représentation que sont notamment les
médias mais d'autres la politique à leur
rôle dans la vision parfois
caricaturales qu'ils ont voulu montrer
des musulmans c'est à dire que vous avez
invité sur les plateaux de télévision
des gens qui étaient des entrepreneurs
identitaire et vous parlez avec des
français de musulmans parfaitement
intégrée qui vous disent ces personnes
ne représentent pas du qui est ce
qu'elle dit c'est pas du tout ce ce que
je pense et c'est hélas il ya des voix
qui s'élèvent le recteur de la mosquée
de paris et puis publie ce texte après
midi il avait fait un texte au moment de
du début du procès est charlie dans le
figaro est très très frappant moi je
regardais c'est istres s'est passé à la
télévision il ya quelques jours le
magnifique film de xavier beauvois
des hommes et des dieux est bon dans ce
film où il ya beaucoup de choses on
comprend on voit très très bien comment
les musulmans qui sont soignés par ces
moines sont les premières victimes des
islamistes qui seront les bourreaux de
ces moines et on voit on voit très très
bien qu'ils cherchent un refuge et est
alors heureusement la france on n'est
pas dans ses extrémités mais on entend
des voix on les lit de français
musulmans qui disent nous ne sommes pas
mais il ne faut pas qu'ils viennent il y
en a même qui disent qu'il ne faut pas
qu'ils viennent installer ici ce que
nous avons fui dans les pays dans
lesquels nous étions voilà écoutons les
musulmans de france et ne pensons pas
que ce sont des terroristes
personne ne dit oui mais il ya un
contexte général est donc cette question
de cet internaute qui dit il ya trop de
migrants et au fond il ya trop de
risques qui vient de l'extérieur non
mais après c'est un peu comme si il
était considéré comme un ennemi
intérieur l'évidence je pense il est
indéniable que la la la ce qu'on appelle
le séparatisme islamistes ou la
partition non par le françois hollande
est le fruit d'une crise de
l'intégration et d'une immigration qui
n'a pas été maîtrisée qui n'a pas été
régulée qui n'a pas été contenue qui
n'accueille créer des ghettos il n'a pas
été pensé je pense que c'est
indiscutable lui d'appeler à créer des
ghettos sociaux et géographiques
donc il ya un vrai sujet et culturels
oui macron d'alors ce qui est
intéressant on pose la question emmanuel
macron relèvera-t-il le défi du
séparatisme islamistes contre contre le
sait pas
va-t-il relever le défi de la lutte
contre le séparatisme pardon et vous
répondez non à 80 3% alors c'est pas une
c'est pas son âge c'est une juste une
question
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que l'on voit
beaucoup une personne en tout cas dans
les internautes qui se sont exprimés
n'exprime de confiance avec garage
macron s'est construit il faut pas
l'oublier s'est construit politiquement
contre la déchéance de nationalité et
contre manuel valls notamment et qu'il a
donné des causes sociales beaucoup à ces
éléments que d'autres qualifiés d'
identitaire ou idéologique et que donc
il n'a pas dans la population de l'image
d'un homme d'autorité sur ces sujets là
et je sais que je me disais il a des
vues électorale c'est évident je sais
pas si en deux ans il pourra rattraper
cette image en gros il ya l'image de
quelqu'un de très compétent en économie
mais dès qu'il ya une dimension
régalienne dans la politique sage à lui
qui qui qui comparé à d'autres figures
incarne l'autorité je pense
il devrait pas changer de pied de cette
manière moi c'est ce que je pense c'est
que je me rappelle quand il a été en
campagne en 2017 comment ils défendent l
idée de sociétés ouvertes et une forme
de multiculturalisme à la française et
donc toute la question je ne sais pas si
le terme multiculturelle s'applique bien
la france mais en tout cas cette idée
d'une république dans laquelle il y
aurait de l'intégration évidemment le
respect de la loi et ensuite la capacité
à utiliser la créativité d'une diversité
culturelle ce que rappelle toujours
patrick weil en disant combien je sais
plus si c'est un tiers des français ou
plus qui ont un grand père étranger
salaires rappelons nous nous sommes un
creuset culturel de longue date et ne
nous avons ton pas une embrouille les
gauloises comptoir il faut activity and
le multiculturalisme et le multi 10 la
france n'est pas la france est une
nation culturelle c'est évident mais là
pas une nation ethnique et donc il y a
des origines multiples mais la france a
développé et moi je il me semble que
c'est son génie propre une une forme
culturelle à laquelle adhèrent ceux qui
la rejoignent
et c'est en ça qu'elle n'est pas une
société multiculturelle société
multiculturelle ce serait new york avec
un quartier c'est un racisme
communautaire voilà où les bons c'est
défendable a aux états unis et oui mais
c'est pas bizarre on peut on peut être
pour nos moyens mais il me semble que
macron été pour qu'elle la il a compris
que les français n'étaient pas pour et
ils essayent de revenir vers ce modèle
d'assimilation
alors pour deux pour illustrer en tout
cas ce scepticisme christophe 78 macro
ne relèvera pas le défi car il en va de
la paix civile dans le pays
citoyen payeur macron se défilera comme
d'habitude vis-à-vis de la bien pensants
ce qui à terme signera la fin notre
république laïque
nicole quand on n'a pas le courage de
nommer les problèmes on ne le résoudra
jamais et lago qui ne vit macron ne
citant déjà pas le caractère islamique
de ce séparatisme il brillera une fois
de plus par son immobilisme
alors la gauche je vous invite à lire
donc les informations d'arthur berda et
christophe cornevin sur ce que devrait
annoncer ce que devrait dire emmanuel
macron demain et notamment vous pourrez
le lire que normalement l'islamisme sera
bien dessinés désigné comme le principal
ennemi d' oncle
emmanuel macron muros et 10h30 demain
normalement s'il respecte les horaires
et ce sera à suivre sur figaro live avec
un débrief de françois-xavier bourmaud
du service politique et de jean marie
guénois du service société du figaro
avec charlotte barrio de nos boys on
suivra ce soir également les dernières
annonces d'olivier verrons qui doit
prendre la parole depuis l'hôpital
parisien bichat on vous pose en
attendant une question est ce que jean
castex a trouvé la bonne méthode pour
faire face à un autre défi celui de la
gestion de la crise provoquée par l'aco
vite 10,9 pour l'heure pour l'heure je
dis ce que on a toujours des surprises
on n'annonce pas de grand changement le
premier ministre a reçu longuement les
maires de lille paris lyon et s'est
entretenu avec ceux de toulouse et
grenoble et notamment à lille il a
accepté selon martine aubry sa mère un
nouveau délai avant d'éventuelles des
durcissements de décisions ça de quoi
ravir de l'autre côté du spectre
quelqu'un par exemple comme le président
du groupe plr au sénat bruno retailleau
je pense qu'il faut d'abord donner la
main ou mer ça fait des semaines que ils
nous ont dit qu'il donnerait la main ou
mais ils ne l'ont pas fait alors là il a
donné la main au maire lui s'il est ce
que jean castex a compris aujourd'hui je
crois en tout cas vous poser la question
de la méthode c'est sûr qu'il a changé
de méthode
après il faut voir ce qui s'est passé là
vous en pensez bien sûr il faut voir ce
qui s'est passé la semaine dernière
c'est que quand il ya renaud muselier
est président de la région paca qui
déposent un recours contre les mesures
de l'état
on a un sentiment on est dans une
situation ubuesque quand on est simple
citoyen c'est à dire que on vit au
rythme des angoisses créé par l'épidémie
de la récession économique de mettre un
masque sur son visage et on voit une
guerre entre l'état et une très grande
région entre le nord et le sud entre
paris et marseille
ça c'est quelque chose franchement si on
avait pu l'éviter moi j'aurais apprécié
donc ils changent et toute la difficulté
c'est aussi cette culture dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons ou laïcs ont certes
j'ai bien entendu ce qu'ont dit certains
maires en dix ans
un coup de fil une demi-heure avant de
prendre la décision et de l'annoncé ça
suffit pas pour dire qu'on concertent
donc on concertent est ce que vraiment
on partage la décision ou est-ce qu'on
repousse la décision en disant on attend
de voir comment l'épidémie progresse ça
c'est un vrai sujet et surtout il ya
cette question du partage des
responsabilités entre l'état et les
collectivités locales qui était un vieux
sujet et un sujets institutionnels et un
sujet culturel puisqu'on parlait de
culture tout à l'heure il faut aussi que
les maires soient prêts à prendre leurs
responsabilités
les décisions lorsqu'il s'agit de kovy
deux sont des décisions souvent
désagréable et populaire donc comment
est ce qu'on va faire je pense que s'il
serait bien c'est de partager aussi des
indicateurs sur les questions sanitaires
c'est que quand olivier vers en fait sa
conférence hebdomadaire
personnellement moi je ne suis pas
médecin j'ai du mal en fait à me rendre
compte réellement de la progression pas
où la dangerosité de la situation est
aujourd'hui entre les conférences
d'olivier ferrand et les prises de
position des maires qui sont plutôt en
fait contre tours autour du confinement
et tout retour en fait de mesures
autoritaires
je crois que les français sont perdus et
ne savent pas vraiment si l'épidémie est
en train de repartir et ne savent pas
vraiment qu'est ce qui est efficace ou
pas et il se demande qui leur dira la
vérité faut plus d'indicateurs enfants
déjà faudrait qu'on ait accès quand en
mars du mois de mars au mois de juin les
journalistes mais d'autres institutions
recevez sur leur téléphone portable ou
son ordinateur un mail ou un whatsapp à
19h30 avec l'intégralité des éléments
épidémiologiques
on avait tous les jours aujourd'hui vous
allez sur santé publie france une fois
sur deux vous les trouvez pas si vous
voulez essayer d'établir les trois
indicateurs définis par olivier ferrand
celui de l'incidence des plus de 65 ans
et un jour sur deux vous le trouvez pas
donc vous ne savez pas comment vous
pouvez le calcul et il ya des ddd des
choses qui sont qui témoigne quand même
je sais pas si tu y es mots et amateurs
i mais ça fait quand même depuis mars
que ça existe cette histoire tous les
week-ends
vous avez un creux parce que tous les
week-ends il ya moins de déclarations
parce que tous les week-ends ya sûrement
moins de gens qui travaillent mais
peut-être que dans 1 quand on est dans
un système épidémique on pourrait
organiser le fait qu'il présente le
week-end afin qu'on puisse travailler au
jour le jour
sur les fiches ça on l'a pas et dernière
chose c'était il ya quinze jours nous en
étions à peu près à une moyenne de 40
morts par jour et toute la crainte c'est
de voir ces chiffres devenir
exponentielle et le vendredi soir à 20h
santé publique france nous donne 123
morts et la plupart des agences de
presse et des télévisions nous explique
il ya 123 morts ce qui veut dire x 3 ça
veut dire que ça a triplé et quand on
regardait en détail on voyait qu'il y
avait 76 morts qui venait d'un hôpital
de l'essonne qui n'avait pas déclaré
le nombre de ces décès qu'au vide depuis
le 15 juillet donc il y avait un
rattrapage bon et quand canton et
c'était vraiment au moment où vous voyez
venir cette seconde vague donc si vous
voulez c'est jouer avec l'anxiété des
gens de façon irresponsable et ça
alimente alors là on est vraiment
d'accord le scepticisme de ceux qui
essayent de suivre ça avec sérieux parce
qu'ils se disent mais met donc ces
chiffres aux fêtes sont pas des fiches
ce sont des vrais chiffres mais ce sont
des données qui ne sont pas établis de
façon précise de façon de penser qu'ils
ne sont pas mises en perspective après
le deuxième élément c'est que en mars il
ya eu un effet de sidération et angoisse
du fait que personne ne savait qualité
ce virus et que tout le monde se disait
je veux être plus ou moins victime est
victime jusqu'à jusqu'à la dernière
heure et jusqu'à la mort aujourd'hui la
population a intégré qu'il ya des
populations vulnérables à risque et que
les autres échappés et donc à partir de
là le consensus qui est permis le
consentement apparaît comme beaucoup
plus difficile donc on sensibilise les
gens sur la tension à l'hôpital ils les
acceptent
les différentes restrictions concon
qu'on leur impose mais ils peuvent se
dire la tension à l'hôpital est dû à
quoi est-ce que c'est parce que c'est
mal organisé pour qu'on n'a pas créé de
réanimation enfin il ya un certain
nombre d'éléments qui peuvent alimenter
aujourd'hui le scepticisme et demain je
pense une certaine défiance vis-à-vis de
la parole publique sur ce sujet là je
reviens aux partis politiques
non mais on va en reparler juste avant
de vendre ce kit est quand même selon le
sondage aux hawks acquis à paraître dans
le figaro
les prochaines heures les français
restent très défiera l'encontre du
gouvernement 76% pensent qu'il ne dit
pas la vérité
75 % ne pense pas qu'il a pris les
bonnes décisions
est ce que c'est ça qui explique le
changement de méthode est selon vous est
est ce que c'est ça qui explique le fait
que jean castex et me sens autant en
scène la réception au camp ennemi en
tout cas à matignon autant en scène la
réception par jean castex des maires des
grandes villes et et qu'il y ait passé
autant de temps sur l'absence de
confiance et quand même des éléments qui
fait qu'on peut on peut comprendre le
sentiment des français puisqu'on va pas
revenir sur l'épisode des masses qui
nous servait à rien qu'il fallait
surtout pas porter ensuite qu'ils sont
devenus obligatoires et sur l'épisode
des tests qui qui était réservé à ceux
qui avaient des symptômes qui ont été
ouverts à tous puis qui maintenant sont
priorisées aux épisodes du traçage qui
fait qu'on a une application que
personne n'a sur son téléphone pas même
le premier ministre alors que c'est elle
qui nous va nous permettre de suivre
l'évolution de l'épidémie donc à partir
de là il a quand même des éléments
objectifs et manifeste de ratés de la
parole publique là c'est indiscutable
ensuite castex et l homme monsieur de
confinement ils essaient de c'était son
rôle et il devait être le premier
ministre de la relance et il se retrouve
le premier ministre turc confinement ou
du trec'h confinement donc c'est très
difficile pour lui là je pense qu'il
faudrait un magicien pour être populaire
il faut il faut confirmer moi non je
pense pas non je pense que je suis tout
à fait d'accord sur le fait que au fond
chacun aujourd'hui s'analyse sur est-ce
que je suis une population à risque ou
pas et en plus il ya énormément
d'articles médicaux très intéressant
d'ailleurs qui explique qu'on vient nous
ne sommes pas en dehors de l'histoire
des populations à risque
nous ne sommes pas à égalité en fonction
de notre système immunitaire donc il ya
un vrai sur truc aussi où chacun dit
du ces intérêts sont en fait on est
aussi dans un truc où la culture
scientifique j'espère d'un certain
nombre de français a pu faire un bon
puisqu'on a découvert aussi qu'on était
un peuple qui avaient une faible culture
scientifique dans cette histoire moi je
voulais dire un mot sur jean castex je
pense que ça pas vu d'ailleurs comme
conséquence une défiance par rapport aux
allées du corps médical qui n'est pas de
beaucoup de culture scientifique on
avait plutôt confiance dans le corps
dans le corps médical et dans les dents
les mandarins et l'a visiblement encore
dans la terre notre louis les voyants se
battre comme des chiffonniers sur les
plateaux télé en tout cas on voit que ça
sans moi je le savais je gère la science
est vraiment c'est un terrain de
bataille il n ya jamais de consensus
entre universitaires et scientifiques
la sq est aussi très intéressant je les
versets ça au débat c'est qu'il ya eu
cette tribune je crois aujourd'hui dans
le parisien de ses médecins qui appelle
au fait de réfléchir sur à l'automne il
ya aussi beaucoup de patients qui ne
sont pas des patients qu'aux vide et
donc la question de préserver des lits
pour ces patients qui ont des
traitements lourds et qui déjà ont pris
trois quatre mois dans la figure c'est
essentiel moi je pense qu'un appel à la
responsabilité qui est franchement bien
et je pense que chacun doit se dire que
la santé oms l'organisant semble en
termes de responsabilité sur castex je
trouve ça bien aussi qu'on est associée
préfets responsables des agences
régionales de santé à la consultation
avec les maires parce que je pense que
ce qui va se passer c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il faut organiser un lien entre les
maires et les services de l'état et
arrêter de faire de la guéguerre ça
c'est un point que vous voyez vous voyez
des maires réclamaient des fermetures de
deux bars et de restaurants vous voyez
des mères en dvd confinement dur je
pense que le sujet c'est que quand on
est responsable qu'on peut travailler
que le préfet et le directeur de l
agence régionale de santé
on peut se dire ben ggl faire ou pas
mais c'est vrai que ce sera compliqué
psychologiquement d'assumer des
décisions impopulaires
et puis il ya quand même le sujet de la
récession économique une vraie question
du chômage
on voit que les patrons de pme sont en
train de dire qu'ils sont en train de
mourir
on voit que montrent une aussi une
fronde contre le plan de relance avec
l'idée qu'il est au fond trop en faveur
des gros et de ce qu'on connaît donc la
question de l'application micro
économique de l'ensemble de nos mesures
ou micro territoriales c'est un point
essentiel je me demande si on va vivre
un épisode en live si je puis dire de
décentralisation réussie de crise c'est
une question qui reposera aussi beaucoup
sur les personnalités dire comment est
ce qu'on fait pour être un
contre-pouvoir efficace et qui prend en
considération le sort de la vie des gens
sans penser toujours à sa réélection
le juste avec question à sainte on ne se
quitte et le fait qu'il est associé les
maires ou qu'ils aient reçu les maires
c'est une bonne chose bien moins après
je crains être ne pas être comme lucile
schmid c'est ne pas tellement croire aux
geôliers à merde ars préfet parce que
moi les hommes tout cas les éléments que
j'ai quand j'ai des maires au téléphone
c'est qu'ils sont assez remontés contre
leur s en considérant que justement
les informations ne viennent pas assez
vite qu'il n'y a pas d'accélération du
travail et qui voudraient quasiment
prendre eux les choses en main j'ai en
tête un maire d'une ville de plus de
100000 habitants qui me raconter ou
quand ils voulaient savoir combien il y
avait de malades dans les ehpad la rs
les appeler une fois par semaine pour
leur donner de chiffre et lui se
déplacer nepad en ehpad pour essayer de
savoir et prendre des décisions en
fonction pour savoir s'il fallait il est
testé ça il me disait non ça n'existe
pas dans l'avenir que par exemple on a
vu la différence entre la rs du grand
est la période de mon film en est la rs
d'île de france où il y avait quelque
chose
le sujet c'est les personnes dans ces
mobilisations de crise mais en fait
c'est moi c'est marrant parce que
j'étais un grand défenseur de l'état
mais cette histoire fait que les
structures administratives et
bureaucratiques et quand même montré
leur immense limites
j'entendais hier mais un médecin libéral
de toulouse qui disait à toulouse il ya
un an il ya des cliniques avec des lits
de réanimation
on pourrait prendre les patients non
qu'ovide pour leur traitement on sait
faire et et par une espèce de deux des
géants que ça ne se fait pas donc est
une espèce de manque d'agilité de
souplesse et on a entendu des défenseurs
de l'hôpital public dire il faut en
appeler aux labos privés pour les tests
sinon on n'y arrivera pas donc là
la rupture de la méfiance entre les
personnes et les instituts centres les
institutions surtout et on aurait pu
croire qu'on tirait les leçons de la
première crise et que tous à travailler
mieux ensemble pour le moment ce n'est
pas le cas c'est ce que vous racontez
dans tout cas de votre médecin libéral
de toulouse j'ai l'impression de relire
un article qui était parue dans le
figaro peu après le confinement où on
avait déjà des directeurs de cliniques
privées qui lançait qui avaient fait
leur service voilà et qui lançait qui
lançait dans la région de lyon notamment
qui est qu'ils lançaient et qui lance l
alerte est effectivement l'impression
qu'on rejoue à chaque fois le même match
la méthode castex est celle d'un
boutique chez rural a cru y en a confié
la gestion d'un centre commercial du
citoyen payeur de timbres à ce noble
citoyens payeurs ce soit et arthur vous
vite c'est essentiel de faire confiance
aux élus locaux les décisions nationales
doivent être adaptées sur les
territoires c'est un bon pas en avant
en tout cas on posait la question jean
castex at il eu raison de donner un
délai aux maires des grandes métropoles
pour évaluer l'efficacité des mesures
contre le coc vide et vous répondez oui
à 63% alors statu quo ou mesures
drastiques ou en étant à marseille en
guadeloupe la conférence de presse de
l'événement à l'arrivée à l'hôpital
lariboisière c'est à suivre
c'est à l'hôpital bichat pardon c'est à
suivre en direct à partir de 18h et on y
revient bien sûr en détail dans les
colonnes du figaro et du figaro.fr merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis merci
vincent merci lucile et on se retrouve
demain même heure même endroit avec
guillaume roquette
[Musique]